elgato has been positioning themselves
as the kind of company that could sell
you
everything you possibly need for your
at-home streaming setup
i'm talking capture cards microphones
lighting
and now acoustic sound paneling that's
right the
stuff you put on your walls when you
want to improve the sound quality of
your room
these are the elgato wave panels not to
be mixed up with the wave
which is confusingly also the name of
their brand of microphone
the starter pack will run you 100 us
dollars for
six panels which is a solid chunk of
change especially since you can go to
sites like
amazon and buy cheaper foam panels in
bulk elgato sent us a starter pack to
try out
so in this video we're going to break
down what you get in the box
how easy installation is whether they
actually make a difference to your sound
quality
and if they are worth that 100 us
dollars
and remember if you enjoy this video
please hit the like and
sub button if you haven't already it
means a lot to us
so your first question might be why
would you want these anyway
well the layout of your space plays a
huge role in the quality of your
sound in short audio can reverberate off
walls and hard surfaces
this affects the sound coming out of
your speakers as well as
audio recordings filling your room with
soft objects such as
couches carpets and curtains can help
absorb
sound but there are still plenty of
places with
hard surfaces that need to be covered
mainly
your walls and ceilings and that is
where acoustic
paneling comes in if your room is
properly treated it can result in
dramatically improved acoustics
so what actually comes with this starter
pack well in the box are six
hexagonal foam panels they are 19 inches
in width running from
point to point the panels are actually
made from
two different materials a low density
foam that is for dampening the high
range frequencies
and a high density fiber behind that for
trapping the mids and lows
the size of the panels are quite nice
and while i'm no expert when it comes to
the world of
foam they are of a nicer quality than
the cheaper
less dense stuff that i've worked
previously with in studios
but what makes this more of a premium
product to me is the
mounting frames which is by far the most
appealing part for me
acoustic foam can be a right pain in the
ass
to set up there are wall friendly
solutions like command strips but those
don't really stick to foam
and then you got things like staple guns
or glues which is
fine in a studio environment but it is
absolutely going to tear up your walls
at home and
you definitely do not want that there
are
wall friendly solutions you can come up
with to mount that kind of cheap foam
but it is going to require more time and
resources on your part
elgato solution is a plastic frame which
you just set up on your wall and then
you mount the foam on
and that's it it is a quick easy clean
solution
and it gives you everything you need out
of the box to make it happen
and to elgato's credit the setup process
was a lot smoother and faster than i
figured it would be
the only construction really required is
to snap the frame pieces into place
and then you're ready to go the next
step being planning out where to put
your panels
this is where elgato falls short
ideally you really want to plan out
where to put your
acoustic paneling to best fit your space
but elgato doesn't provide any resources
or
tips either in their instructions or
their website
the best you get is a couple of designs
that they offer you to try out
okay but which one's gonna give me the
best sound so you're gonna need to do
some extra research
on your own to figure out where the best
position is to fit your personal setup
speaking of i live in a small
one-bedroom apartment and my computer
setup is
in my living room which is by no means
the
optimal situation for this kind of setup
but
i'm just working with what i have which
i imagine is the case
for most people so for my situation i've
decided the best course of action is to
set
up all my panels right behind my monitor
and speakers which
should help dampen my voice now when it
comes to installation
you have two options sticky adhesive
for smooth walls and screws for rougher
walls with the recommendation of using
both for extra stability now my walls
are pretty rough
but i am not really that interested in
putting holes in them
so i ended up using the sticky adhesive
and it worked out pretty
well just remember to wipe down your
wall with a mix of water and
isopropyl alcohol first now once you get
your first frame set up it's as simple
as using the sides to line up the rest
and then
joining them all with the connecting
piece you then place the foam panels on
and you're pretty much done a painless
setup in my opinion
and pretty easy to take down and move
somewhere else if needed
the sticky adhesive that comes with is
pretty much exactly like the command
strips you can find
in any store if you need replacements
now comes the big question do they
actually make a difference
for this i've recorded two simple audio
tests before and after
hello this is me testing my microphone
before we set up the elgato
wave panels this is me testing my
microphone
after we've set up the elgato wave
panels
i'll admit that at first i didn't really
feel like there was much of a difference
when i was just going about my daily
routine recording vo for work
but now that i've compared them side by
side it's actually a pretty noticeable
change
thanks to the panels my audio is softer
and
less sharp which is more pleasing on the
ears
you can see this when comparing the
waveform of my
audio the peaks in the audio where i set
up the wave panels is a lot
shorter because there isn't any reverb
like i said i was originally skeptical
of the actual improvements these wave
panels could make to my audio
but having now listened to it i'm
pleasantly surprised and happy with the
results
the question now is whether it's worth
that 100 dollar
price tag you will undoubtedly be saving
money buying the cheaper stuff
in bulk but the quality of that foam
isn't gonna be on par with the wave
panels
there's also the matter of setup i
cannot express
just how much of a pain it is to set up
that cheaper foam paneling and how much
damage it can potentially do to your
walls
the easy installation is a huge plus for
me
and yes they are a little expensive but
once you start to compare them to the
professional grade acoustic paneling
which ranges in the
hundreds of dollars they start to look a
lot more reasonable
you're also paying for the presentation
and appearance
of professionalism the sleek hexagonal
design
doesn't look ugly on your walls and
appears well on camera on a set
i won't deny that after i first set them
up i did feel more professional during
my voiceover i was originally ready to
write these off as a
unnecessarily expensive version of the
cheaper foam you can get on amazon
however the quality of the foam is
actually really nice and the ease of
installation
makes it a pretty easy recommendation
for me especially if you're interested
in improving the sound quality
of your at-home streaming setup hey
everybody thank you for watching this
video hopefully it's giving you some
good information
if you are interested in checking out
the elgato wave panels
or you've just now learned about sound
paneling in general and
want to check that out for yourself
regardless of what foam
you end up going with again as i
mentioned at the beginning of the video
if you haven't already please give us a
like and sub
it means a lot to us it tells us uh that
these videos are doing well and that you
guys like them and that you want to see
more like these such as previous videos
that i've done
such as ones where i compared two fifty
dollar headsets one from razer and one
from hyperx so why not check that out
thanks for watching
[Music]
you